This episode was made possible by generous
supporters on Patreon.
Hey Crazies.
Quantum mechanics is weird.
The concepts are so alien to us, which I think
adds to their appeal.
If we're being honest though, I kind of hate Quantum.
But what I hate even more are the myths people
develop about it.
I know people still have them because I keep
getting comments like this.
So let’s set the record straight.
Myth #1: Sometimes electrons behave like particles.
Sometimes they behave like waves.
It’s called Wave-Particle Duality.
False!
Before you freak out, let me explain.
First, we have to be careful with the word
"particle."
A particle is vaguely defined as a small portion
of matter,
which is always true for things like electrons,
protons, and neutrons.
No matter what their behavior, they are always
small portions of matter,
so they’re always particles.
That’s why we can call all of these things
elementary particles.
But the "particle" in wave-particle duality
is saying much more than that.
It implies that those small portions of matter,
those electrons, protons, and neutrons,
also exhibit exactly the same behavior as
normal objects.
For clarity, let’s just call this an object
instead of a particle from now on.
That means we’ll call it wave-object
duality instead.
Second, the justification for this idea usually
comes from the double-slit experiment,
which I’m really tired of hearing about
and I’m sure you are too.
So here’s the quick version:
Say you’ve got two walls, but the one in front has two openings.
If you launch a bunch of paint balls at the
first wall,
a pattern develops on the second wall.
We’ll call this pattern "object behavior."
If you do this same experiment with sound,
you get a very different pattern.
We’ll call this "wave behavior."
It’s a way for us to know if a small thing
is an object or a wave.
But it gets weird when we do the experiment
with microscopic things like electrons.
If we only detect the electrons at the second
wall, we see wave behavior.
If we detect the electrons at both walls,
we see object behavior.
It would appear that what quantum particles
are depends on the circumstances.
But that’s not actually the case.
Electrons, protons, and neutrons are always
particles, but are never truly objects.
But didn’t the experiment just show that...
No. No, it didn’t.
Yes, we sometimes get patterns like this for
particles,
but we have to be careful about what we think
that means.
The double-slit experiment doesn’t tell
us that particles behave two different ways.
It tells us that our ordinary notions of behavior
are wrong.
Quantum particles do not have wave-object
duality.
They are never objects.
They are always waves.
Quantum particles only behave one way.
Their way!
What are you going to do about, punk?
Myth #2: When particles are measured, they
stop obeying quantum mechanics
and start obeying classical mechanics.
[Giggle] No.
While it is true that a quantum wave function
collapses after a measurement,
you’re misinterpreting the word “collapse.”
You keep using that word.
I do not think it means what you think it
means.
I can actually address this by expounding
on something I said during the last myth.
Quantum particles are never objects.
They are always waves.
So they’re always governed by quantum mechanics.
Hmm, an example might be helpful.
Here’s the wave function for an electron
in a very simple box.
You can see it could be just about anywhere
in the box.
If we’d like the electron to have a more
definite location, we need to measure it.
The easiest way to do that is with a photon.
The interaction with the photon changes the
wave function.
That change is called a collapse.
Now the electron is here
ish.
We can’t forget the Heisenberg Uncertainty
Principle.
It says we can’t ever know any property
exactly.
Most people are familiar with the one relating
position and momentum.
These are typically called uncertainties,
but that’s a terrible name.
They’re actually standard deviations, because
quantum is all about probability.
What’s a standard deviation?
OK OK OK.
Here’s a crash course in statistics.
For example, school exams are scored from
0 to 100%.
Traditionally, those scores are distributed
something like this
with the mean average right in the middle.
The standard deviation tells us something
about the spread of the scores.
Roughly 68% of them should be within one standard
deviation of the average,
roughly 95% within two standard deviations,
and so on.
If gives you an idea of the width of the curve.
The same kind of thing happens with a quantum
wave function.
This position here is just an average.
It’s not exact.
The standard deviation is not zero and, just
like with the exam scores,
it gives you an idea of the spread or width
of this curve.
Can’t I narrow this down some more?
Yes, you can make the standard deviation smaller,
but never zero.
The higher the energy of the photon,
the more localized you can make the electron.
But these two standard deviations, position
and momentum, multiplied
must be greater than this number, so neither
one of them can be zero.
On top of that, the more definite you make
the position,
the less definite you make the momentum.
In other words, the less wavy you make the position,
the more wavy you make the momentum.
And all properties of a particle are related
like this in one way or another.
You can’t escape quantum mechanics.
Myth #3: Reality only exists because conscious
observers exist.
Alright look, I understand how easy this misconception
is to come to.
I had the same misconception a long time ago.
It’s also philosophically interesting,
but it’s simply not true.
Reality would exist whether we exist or not.
The universe does not require human beings.
It does not require a conscious mind.
It does not require life.
This electron didn’t change from this wave
into this wave,
because a person was looking.
It changed because it interacted with a photon.
The human experimenter was an unnecessary
part of that event.
The same goes for the double-slit experiment.
The experimenter is unnecessary.
All that matters is the interaction.
Particles interacted with each other long
before life evolved in this universe
and they will continue to do so long after
life goes extinct.
So let’s recap.
One!
Quantum particles do not have wave-object
duality.
They are never objects.
They are always waves.
Two!
Quantum particles always obey quantum mechanics.
And three!
Quantum mechanics does not require conscious
observers.
Stop jumping to conclusions!
If you have any questions about quantum mechanics,
please ask in the comments.
Thanks for liking and sharing this video.
Don’t forget to subscribe if you’d like
to keep up with us.
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.
So, I said “doobly doo” in the last video
and some of you were like:
OMG! You stole that from so-and-so!
For the record, everyone stole that from Wheezy
Waiter.
You know, this guy.
Anyway crazies, thanks for watching!